the Democrats have now spent two
generations explaining that the true
threat to free speech resides on the
religious right those fists Nick John
Lithgow from Footloose types you just
can't wait to smash their Bibles in the
faces of those who only want to read
that a lesbian pornography magazines in
reality there's only one side of the
American political debate fully
committed to destroying the First
Amendment the left on Thursday former
head of the Democratic National
Committee and former Vermont governor
Howard Dean's we did this quote hate
speech is not protected by the First
Amendment knew this is ignorance of the
highest order
of course hate speech is protected by
the First Amendment there are only a few
categories of speech that aren't
protected by the First Amendment
so-called fighting words specific and
deliberate calls to violence child
pornography defamation but there is no
category of hate speech here for a
simple reason why you deem hate speech
may be political speech you just don't
like in Canada for example the law has
forced commentators like Mark Stein into
court for criticizing Islam this is a
violation of freedom and the First
Amendment doesn't contemplate it using
hate speech as a rubric for political
speech you don't like its journey of
thought the ensuite came in response to
a tweet from Stephen greenhouse of the
New York Times regarding Berkeley
canceling a speech from commentator and
Coulter said free speech defenders don't
forget Ann Coulter once said my only
regret with Timothy McVeigh is heated
out and go to the New York Times
building this may be dumb speech it may
be a bad joke it may be offensive and
nasty and terrible it is also protected
as anyone with a modicum of First
Amendment understanding knows but the
Democrats have long wanted to gut the
First Amendment they want to prohibit
political spending from their opponents
they want to prohibit people from using
biologically correct pronouns to
describe transgender people they want to
ban hate speech
they hate the First Amendment because
they see its protections as incompatible
with the collective good the collective
good protecting non offensive speech
only this is why we have a constitution
it's why we have a First Amendment
that's why Democrats certainly can't be
trusted with protecting either of them
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
okay so have a lot to get to today you
should subscribe right now over a daily
wire because if you subscribe right now
a daily wire then you can be part of the
mailbag we will be doing live mailbag
questions today on the special Friday
edition of the Ben Shapiro show I know
if I get to call it a special Friday
edition given the fact that I took two
days off this week but in any case we
will and pretend that we're giving you
some sort of favor but I want to talk at
length today about a video that's going
around on Facebook that has made all
sorts of waves and this is this video of
Neil deGrasse Tyson he calls it the most
important video that he has ever done
and this video is about four minutes and
30 seconds we're going to watch the
whole thing but we're going to break it
up and we're going to we're going to
talk about it the thing has 17 million
views on Facebook as of now it's
probably approaching 18 now it's all
about science and the value of science
and I want to explain what I think Neil
deGrasse Tyson is doing that's so
damaging and what exactly the left is
doing with language like this so here's
Neil deGrasse Tyson talking about the
most important video he has ever done
[Music]
how did America rise up from a backwoods
country to be one of the greatest
nations the world has ever known we
pioneered industries and all this
required the greatest innovations in
science and technology in the world and
so science is a fundamental part of the
country that we are pausing there for
one second so here's what is interesting
about what he's saying here number one
science is not defined whether a nation
is good or bad in Nazi Germany was
actually pretty scientifically literate
until they started banning Jews for
Jewish science they I mean they
developed the v2 rocket they developed
all sorts of they had several Nobel
Prize winners people who actually
couldn't accept a Nobel Prize in science
because the Germans didn't want them to
science does not mean morality but it is
important to note one of the reasons
that the United States has always been
so scientifically advanced is because
the United States was always a limited
government place that didn't seek to
suck resources out of the pocket of
private industry and redistribute it
redistribute of nations have trouble
with scientific patents the United
States does not we've always been the
world leader or at least for the last
century and a half of been a world
leader in scientific patents and that's
also because there's a spirit of freedom
that exists in the United States that
does not exist in big government places
elsewhere deGrasse Tyson won't talk
about why it is that the United States
is so scientifically advanced it just
sort of assumes it sort of assumes we're
really scientifically advanced but then
he doesn't discuss why that is because
he's a big government guy who thinks
there should be more social
redistribution ISM ignoring the fact
that it is the lack of social
redistribution as admitted the fact that
there's a huge amount of private
industry in the United States that has
helped push science forward he continues
but in this the 21st century when it
comes time to make decisions about
science it seems to me people have lost
the ability to judge what is true and
what is not what is reliable what is not
reliable
what should you believe what you do not
believe and when you have people who
don't know much about science standing
in denial of it and rising to power that
is a recipe for the complete dismantling
of our informed democracy let us demand
that educators around America teach
evolution not as fact but his theory
increasing number of parents showing
skepticism about vaccinations voters
have approved a ban on GMOs climate
change unproven science positive for
second okay so here is the problem with
some of what he is saying here so I
agreed there are a lot of people who
don't know what is true and what is not
I've spoken about this in political
sense I speak about this with regard to
fact all the time you notice that that
he never talked about Sciences less
doesn't like rights he never talks about
the science of abortion right never
talks about the science of child
development he never talks about the
science regarding transgenderism and
people who literally have the fantasy
that people with chromosomes that say X
and Y and our full email can be females
we just give them hormone treatment and
a few breast implants right he never
talks about that he always talks about
climate change or evolution but here is
part of the problem Neil deGrasse Tyson
just like a lot of people who's expert
in his field and I know their people
have questioned his expertise but he
knows more science than I do so he's
more expert than I am so I'm not going
to go into that but I will say this Neil
deGrasse Tyson is a guy who is posited
that there ought to be a country called
rational iya where people who agree with
neil degrasse tyson get to vote on
rational basis alone what he's really
calling for here is a scientific goal
lugar ki he's not calling for a
democracy he's not worried about an
informed democracy he wants to be able
to cram down his point of view on
everybody else so he'd take for example
what pence is saying here now what pence
is saying here is that there should be
it's not forbidden for creationism to be
taught in local schools we shouldn't be
saying that evolution is the only way to
think about things godless evolution is
the only way to think about things I may
disagree
with Mike Pence in fact when it comes to
the teaching of science and the teaching
of creationism I don't think they're
incompatible but I also I'm not sure the
creationism should be taught in science
class because I don't think it's a
scientifically provable hypothesis that
being said it is not my job to say to
the American people that you on a local
level cannot vote for how to raise your
children Neil deGrasse Tyson thinks that
you should be able he should be able to
tell you what your kids should learn and
not learn he's not worried about
informed democracy again when Mike Pence
says let us demand that educators around
America teach evolution not as fact that
it's Theory what he's really saying is
let's stop using the federal government
to cram down our version of what we
think is true on local communities I may
believe in evolution the same way that
deGrasse Tyson does but Pence is not
wrong in the sense that it is a
scientific theory just as all theories
are scientific theories this has a lot
of evidence to back it it's a theory
that that is certainly not evidence less
but the idea that schools should teach
evolution exclusively in science and
lead creationism for Bible class I may
agree with it in a consenting democracy
people get to vote for what they want
and they may be informed about Neil
deGrasse Tyson's opinions on evolution
and they can still deny it okay even if
they don't like what he's saying they
sold the right to deny and they have the
right to raise their children as they
see fit on this score without reference
to Neil deGrasse Tyson's opinions again
consent he may not like it because he
thinks that consent actually requires
the children not learn but it's that
same consent that allows us to have a
free country that allows for all the
sorts of economic and scientific
development that have occurred over time
is then he continues that's not the
country I remember growing up in not
that we didn't have challenges
I'm old enough to remember the 60s in
the 70s got a hot war in a cold war
civil rights and all this was going on
but I don't remember any time where
people were standing in denial of what
science was stopped at Devon so number
one that is not true there are always
been people who have stood and denounced
what science is again transgenderism and
abortion he never mentions them in the
1970s Paul Ehrlich was considered the
professor from Stanford was considered
the breaking wave of science and anyone
who said there was not going to be mass
starvation across the plan and thanks to
scarcity of resources those people were
considered quote denialists right they
were denialists who didn't understand
the catastrophe that was going to spring
upon Earth's environment it didn't
happen not only did it not happen
resources got more plentiful humans got
smarter and how we were going to apply
those resources and now we have seven
billion people on the planet when forty
years ago we had half that so the idea
that we are going to that you know Oh
science today is stopped like this is
the science today is what it is and in
the 60s and 70s you know we were more
respectful of science I don't think we
were more respectable science in the 60s
and 70s I think that's nonsense I don't
see any evidence to support that
whatsoever I mean there are people who
are hippie flower children in the 60s
and 70s they're still hippie flower
children today there are people who deny
scientific issues then there are people
who deny scientific issues today that's
just the way things are but what he's
trying to paint is this picture of
science is going like this and then
Trump gets elected and boom scientists
the floor science is going like this
Obama was a scientific guy in the boom
science just takes a plummet off the
cliff that is not accurate it's just not
accurate and then he gets into his real
point and his real point is to conflate
his political views about global warming
with scientific evidence about global
warming and this is what the left one
wants to do here this is why they call
people denialists if they don't agree
with their political solutions so we're
going to go through in a second what the
science actually says about global
warming according to the IPCC which is
the left source I mean the source that
they like the most it's also probably
the most credible source when it comes
to climate science in any case here's
what he has to say and you can see him
conflating his ideology with scientific
fact here he sings about science
that it is an entire exercise in finding
what is true the hypothesis you tested I
get a result a rival of mine double
checks it because they think I might be
wrong they perform an even better
experiment than I did and they find out
any this experiment matches oh my gosh
we're onto something here and out of
this rises a new emergent truth it does
it better than anything else we have
ever come up with as human beings stop
again in the amount of the amount of
Eire in his voice you know people who
are denying scientific truth is there
anyone out there who's denying the the
scientific basis for science is there
anybody who like who's the who the
actual anti science person they may
disagree with the conclusion they're
drawing but who's out there going
hypothesis being tested bad that's just
terrible but again this is all designed
to kind of raise your emotional Needle
you raise the raise the emotional
temperature so then when you gets to
this climate change point go yeah
climate change that's the thing that's
super important and we should listen to
Neil deGrasse Tyson solutions this is
science
it's not something to toy with
it's not something to say I choose not
to believe equals mc-squared
you don't have that option when you have
an established scientific emergent truth
it is true whether or not you believe in
it and the sooner you understand that
the faster we can get on with the
political conversations about how to
solve the problems that face us let's
stop there for one second okay so and
there's one line there that I do take
issue with he says this is science it's
not something to toy with it's not
something to say I choose not to believe
in e MC squared u dou MC squared you
don't have that option well frankly you
do have that option it just makes you
stupid right and this is the case that
you should be making you should be
making the case not that you don't have
that option because that sounds fistic
you do have that option he should be
making the convincing case as to why the
science he is citing is important and
true and he should be putting that out
there as opposed to just railing against
the wind about how there's all these
people who don't like science and here's
the thing again he says that you know
the emergent truths are the most
important thing this is science it's not
something to toy with you don't get to
have an opinion that can flix with
science again half of the left
scientific opinions are false on
transgenderism on abortion those are the
two most obvious cases but even with
regard to global warming so let's talk
about what the the established
scientific consensus says so it is true
the established scientific consensus
says that the earth is warming the
established scientific consensus also
says that human activity has been a
large contributor to global warming
there's sort of deviation as to how much
of global warming people attribute some
people say ten percent some people say
thirty some people say fifty but there's
no question that there is some amount of
human activity that has had an impact on
the warming trend on the globe thanks to
the greenhouse gas effect the question
is how large that effect is and the
question is what we are going to do
about that okay now all of that that I
have just said is not denying the
reality of global warming or human
activity in involving global warming but
he's not going to like what I say next
Lauren Kass who's a columnist over at
foreign policy magazine at the Manhattan
Institute he's written about this and
what he says that the IPCC the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change from the UN consistently project
real but manageable costs over the next
century he says quote I'm scientific
questions the gold standard summary is
the assessment report created every few
years by thousands of scientists under
the auspices of the UN inter-government
panel on climate change by averaging
widely varying projections and assuming
no aggressive efforts to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions they estimate
in an increase of three to four degrees
Celsius which is five to seven degrees
Fahrenheit by the year 2100 okay in a
hundred years
The Associated rise in sea levels over
the course of the 21st century according
to the IPCC is 0.6 meters which is about
two feet even stipulating that
adaptations will displace hundreds of
millions of people that this placement
will not happen all at once spread over
decades such a disruption would look a
little different from the status quo and
this is the point this is the part where
you know the where the alarmism that
you're seeing in this video this sort of
alarm that science is being overridden
that people are ignoring science in
favor of other things again it's just
not that the tone and tenor is so
desperate in this video and it's not
really called for so there are lots of
solutions that people have proposed the
prove the ones the he proposes are
basically vast government regulations
international regulations that aren't
going to be particularly effective that
destroy vast swath of the global economy
right now now one of the things I
presume that he would oppose is
additional fracking even though natural
gas is significantly friendlier for
greenhouse gas emissions for carbon
emissions than for example coal coal is
really not great for carbon emissions
natural gas is much better but I assume
that he wouldn't be in favor of natural
gas he wants massive government
subsidies for failed green energy
projects he wants massive tariffs and
taxes on carbon emissions right all of
these things may not even be necessary
and again we have to discuss whether
they would do anything and that's where
there's a tremendous amount of
uncertainty so to pretend that science
has now suggested a solution or that
science is very specific about the
problem is just not totally accurate on
talk a little bit more about this in one
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at upside comm so
if you're a business traveler and you
like to and you're traveling alone right
you fly all over the country all the
time and it's hard to find seats it's
hard to find good cheap seats right now
go to upside comm upsides out comments a
brand new service is founded by a guy
named Jay Walker and he founded
Priceline and they're a new kind of
travel company you buy your air and
hotel as a bundle and you get a gift
card worth a lot of money the typical
gift card is worth about $200 on US
trips
300 and $500 on overseas trips to gift
cards from an Amazon or 40 plus top
national retailers you get to choose you
can even
why some of that money back towards your
ticket if you just want a cheaper ticket
your company saves money and you get the
gift card so it's a cheaper ticket plus
you get the gift card and you don't have
to give it to your company you're
already buying travel now you get that
$200 to gift card on average you get
hundreds of dollars also for making
small changes so upside daikon makes it
really easy to search for a cheaper trip
so you don't just want to fly into LAX
you want to see what the surrounding
prices look like flying into Long Beach
or flying into Burbank and so you can
check that really quickly and and you
can do that and see the different prices
at the different airports very easily
you can use it every time you buy a trip
if you travel twice a week you can use
it two times a week there's no limit on
trips there's no limit on the gift cards
you buy those airline tickets in the
hotel together from one low price it's
no long list of flights and rooms and
prices in trying to bundle them together
you just do it for one low price and
again you get the gift card within 72
hours so go to up side calm and use my
promo code been radio listeners use the
promo code been and you receive at least
$200 in gift cards with your minimum
purchase upside comm again up side comm
use that promo code been receive $200 in
gift cards with your minimum purchase
one more time upside comm and use that
promo code been make sure you use the
promo code so that you get that minimum
that $200 in gift cards with your
minimum purchase okay so back to this
back to this video here is finally what
Neil deGrasse Tyson suggests about what
his solutions would be on this global
warming stuff yes
so once you understand that humans are
warming the planet you can then have a
political conversation about that you
can say well should we are the carbon
credits do we do this do we put a tariff
on it do we fund do we subsidize those
those have political answers and every
minute one is in denial you are delaying
the political solution that should have
been established years ago
as a voter as a citizen scientific
issues will come before you and isn't it
worth it to say all right let me at
least become scientifically literate so
I can think about these issues and act
intelligently upon recognize what
science is and allow it to be what it
can and should be in the service of
civilization
and what I love about this is that you
see all these beautiful pictures of
American cities from at night over sky
you see the electricity throughout the
American cities what he doesn't say is
that his solutions on global warming
would likely shut down but cities right
see some of the electricity go out it's
this idea that the left likes to put out
there that they are just pro science and
you are just anti science if you
disagree with their solutions that's the
problem I can agree with Neil deGrasse
Tyson on evolution I can agree with Neil
deGrasse Tyson that the world is warming
and that human activity has something to
do with that I don't have to agree on
the solutions that he proposes but if I
don't agree on the solutions that he
proposes I assume he'll call me a
denialist because obviously if I knew
science then I would agree with him okay
so I want to talk about president Trump
and and healthcare shape up what what
exactly is happening there does it look
like that's going to be revived on taxes
what's happening there as well plus
Sarah Palin and Ted Nugent go to the
White House how big a deal is it
animals with mailbag but you have to go
over to Daley wire calm for all of that
Daley wired.com $8 a month gets you a
subscription plus if you get the annual
subscription right now you get a free
copy of the Arroyo fictional film set on
the southern border all about a farmer
trying to save his ranch from drug
cartels using it as a thoroughfare
really really good film daily wired.com
become an annual subscriber or if you
just want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud become a subscriber
at iTunes and leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
podcast conservative podcast in the
United States
[Music]
you